[Music]
as we come to the close of 2018 we are
finishing up another year of the worlds
of speculative fiction series as year
three and it's time once again to poll
you viewers subscribers followers and
other fans to see who you would like to
see make it into the next series I've
got three slots open you're going to
leave your ideas in the comments below
but don't do it quite yet because I've
got plenty of other things to tell you
including who we've got lined up for the
nine slots already before I begin if
you're just watching this and you're not
quite sure what I'm talking about the
worlds of speculative fiction series is
a local talk series that I give here
partnering with the Brookfield public
library and people have been coming to
this for three years we've got quite a
few regulars I began with some classic
fantasy and science fiction authors
we've moved into horror alternate
history a couple other genres as well
and this year we're gonna be doing
something really cool in 2019 I decided
that this time around I would begin by
talking about some really really classic
speculative fiction so the first four
slots are reserved for you might call
these seminal authors we're gonna start
with Edgar Allen Poe in January then go
on to G K Chesterton in February in
March we're gonna look at Mary Shelley
so you know Frankenstein is gonna be in
there but not just Frankenstein and and
then in April we're gonna talk about
Lewis Carroll and his Alice stories and
some of his other stuff as well then
we're gonna go on and and do some
authors a few of whom were left over
from last year but some are ones I've
been wanting to get to Tanith Lee we're
gonna look at her Flat Earth series
Piers Anthony and his xanthe novels
which I read as a kid and really enjoyed
Gordon Dickinson's child cycle novels
the door sigh also called write and then
we're gonna look at somebody
from my home state of Wisconsin who
played an important role in not just
horror but speculative fiction as well
August Derleth the person who found in
Arkham House press and will finish up in
September with Carl Edward Wagner the
author of the Kane series of books
somebody who I started reading as a kid
and really enjoyed and then October
November December those are to be
determined so you can vote you can weigh
in first what we're gonna do is we're
gonna have a first round where people
put comments and the authors they get
the most comments saying hey I want you
to do this person and I'm not gonna say
any authors because I thought a
prejudice it but if you like author acts
just say hey I'd like you to do author X
and the ones that get the most comments
I will put into a runoff will pick say
the top six and we'll do this later on
in December of 2018 you can get in on
that vote as well
I will weight it so that patreon
supporters get a little bit more voting
power than other people but in general
you know the public will decide so if
you're really into the the series if
you've been following along with it if
you've been one of the people who signed
up for the free class that I created to
house the videos and provide the
resources which I have to get around
updating but but it has a lot of content
for you already if you're one of the
fans of that you're gonna want to get in
on this so you have some say in the
thinkers that I'm going to do so one
more time we're doing Poe Chesterton
Shelly Carol Lee Anthony Dickinson
Derleth and Wagner those are the ones
that I've chosen you can pick anybody
else who you like within the realm of
speculative fiction so that means horror
that means fantasy that means sci-fi
that means science fantasy that means
alternate history that means all these
other sort of things that fall under the
rubric of speculative fiction so put
your comments below and I look
or to seeing what you guys have in mind
for what I ought to do in 2019
[Music]